All right.
Good morning.
Let's get started.
So the last lecture we showed
you how to go digital.
The fact that going digital had
some key benefits for us.
And what we'll do today is go
inside the digital gate.
Let's do a quick review.
We began life by observing
nature.
We said those Maxwell's
equations are tough.
Let's simplify our lives by
discretizing or lumping matter.
So we got the lumped circuit
abstraction.
Then we had this noise problem
here.
In order to be able to handle
that let's do some more
discretization,
some more lumping.
So we said let's discretize
values and deal with two levels,
a high and a low.
That's where the binary voltage
levels come up,
a high level and a low level.
And then we said that in
discretizing it we have to make
some assumptions.
We have to impose some
constraints on ourselves.
Just as with the lumped matter
discipline, we imposed a couple
of constraints in going from the
continuous matter world to a
lumped matter world.
Similarly, we have to impose
some discipline on ourselves,
some constraints on ourselves
in going from the continuous
value regime to the digital
value regime.
And that discipline is called
the static discipline.
And what the static discipline
says is that if you have senders
and receivers in a digital
system then they all need to
adhere to some standard.
If I was a sender I had to
adhere to some tough output
standards.
I had to be sure to shift
values that exceeded some high
voltage threshold.
And if I was sending a low
value I had to make sure my
values were lower than some
output low voltage threshold.
Similarly, if I was the
receiver then I had to guarantee
to recognize as a one all
voltages that where above some
input high voltage threshold.
And similarly I had to
guarantee to recognize as a zero
voltages that were below some
input low voltage threshold.
So provided senders and
receivers in a system adhere to
these voltage levels,
to this discipline then they
would all very comfortably work
correctly in a digital system.
Then we also said that once you
deal with such values,
one you deal with digital
values we can now postulate a
bunch of digital elements that
process these values in a manner
very reminiscent of our analog
circuits where we get analog
signals.
And you've already learned how
to process analog signals.
You've learned about resistor
dividers and so on and so forth.
You feed in an analog signal
and you get an output analog
signal as well.
Now, here the resistor in the
analog domain,
elements like resistors and
voltage sources were the symbols
that you dealt with.
Here, in the digital domain,
the primitive elements that we
will be using are called gates.
As one example,
this is called the NAND gate.
So we looked at the AND gate in
the previous lecture.
This is an example of another
gate called the NAND gate.
The NAND gate has the following
truth table.
Our two inputs A and B and this
output C.
And the NAND gate works as
follows.
The output --
In English I can describe its
properties as the output is a
high at all times when at least
one of these inputs is a low
value.
So it's high whenever at least
one input is a low.
So it's high here.
It's high here.
Oops, it's high here,
high here.
And when, oops.
And when both inputs are a high
the output is a low.
This is a NAND gate.
Notice that these are exactly
complimentary to the AND gate.
The AND gate outputs were
0-0-0-1.
And the AND gate symbol looked
like this.
In general, notice that this
little bubble here,
it's called a bubble.
That bubble implies a negation,
an inversion.
So we take the AND gate,
invert the output and negate
the output and you get the NAND
gate.
So these elements are
combinational gates.
And in combinational gates they
adhere to two properties.
One is that they must satisfy
the static discipline.
All the systems,
all the elements in our
repertoire in the digital domain
need to satisfy the static
discipline.
And the properties of a
combinational gate are that its
outputs are a function of inputs
alone.
In other words,
it doesn't store any state or
doesn't store any history inside
it.
You can figure out its output
just by looking at the inputs at
that instant.
Think of it as a completely
transparent entity where its
output reflects some function of
the inputs at every instant of
time.
So I'll show you an example of
a digital circuit.
So much as I could interconnect
resistors and voltage sources
and current sources to build
analog circuits,
I can now build digital
circuits using primitive
elements such as these.
So, for example,
I could build a simple circuit
that looked like this,
two inputs A and B here,
I get an output.
And I feed that to another NAND
gate with another input C.
This device is called an
inverter.
The inverter simply flips the
sense of the input.
So if C is a 1 the output is a
0, if C is a 0 the output
becomes a 1.
It's an inverter.
It simply inverts its input.
Yet another primitive device.
And this is my output D.
So there are three gates in
this design.
And I can quickly write down
what the output looks like using
some very simple Boolean algebra
or dealing with Boolean values
here.
So for AND gate the output is A
and B.
Remember dot is a short form
for and.
But there's a negation,
inversion, so represent
inversions with a bar.
So my output is A dot B bar.
There is a C here.
So this is my output C bar.
And this is a NAND gate.
So it takes one input A dot B.
It takes the second input C bar
and ANDs those and inverts them.
So that's the output.
So there are three gates in
this example.
So you can think of building
very complicated circuits
containing large numbers of
gates.
In fact, the microprocessors
that you use in your laptop
contain a large number of gates.
Can someone guess how many
gates are in the Pentium IV,
roughly?
Approximate,
how many?
How many gates in a Pentium IV?
40 million.
100 million.
In the Pentium IV you have on
the order of 20 million gates.
20 million gates in the Pentium
IV.
And life begins in 002.
Here you learn about onsies and
twosies, and in the real world
you will be dealing with tens of
millions of gates.
But this is for the Pentium IV.
My research group at Laboratory
for Computer Science built a
chip called the Raw chip.
And this chip has 3 million
gates.
And so there are several
undergraduate students involved
in this project in their third
year, and they're beginning to
deal with millions of gates.
So the key thing to remember is
that 002 provides the
foundations where you make the
switch from the analog signal to
the digital signal or from
continuous matter to lumped
matter.
And learn about the foundations
of these primitive elements.
And by the end of this course
you will begin dealing with
small systems,
analog systems that contain on
the order of 10 to 20 primitive
elements.
You will also begin dealing
with small digital systems that
contain tens of gates.
In your final project you will
build a mixed signal circuit
involving an audio playback
system.
You will have digital data
stored in a memory chip and you
will build a circuit to extract
that data, filter it and then
convert it to the analog domain
and then play it on a set of
speakers.
And that has on the order of
about 50 to 100 primitive
elements.
So by the end of 002 you will
have learned to deal with
hundreds of elements.
And then you will take other
courses like 004 and so on where
you will then make the leap to
learn further abstractions that
will take you from subsystems to
systems with millions of gates.
So the key is to manage the
complexity of dealing with
millions of gates it's all about
abstractions.
You have to build abstractions
and double abstractions so you
can deal with complexity.
So the rest of EECS will take
you from three gates to 20
million gates and software
systems that operate on 20
million gates or whatever.
So there is still a ways to go.
Lorenzo, our friend has gone to
bring a demonstration that we
forgot to bring today.
That will show you that little
digital circuit in a mock up
form.
So what's today's lecture
about?
Today's lecture is going to be
about what's inside a gate?
How to build a gate.
Once you build a gate you can
then put millions of them into
computer systems or analog
systems or other sorts of
systems.
And what we'll do here is
understand what's inside this
abstraction.
This is an abstract element
that looks like a little circle
and a line with some stuff
inside it, with some properties.
But someone's got to build
that.
It doesn't come from nature.
You don't go and harvest gates
from trees, you got to go build
that, and someone has got to do
that.
So what to learn here is how do
we go about building a gate?
And here you will see
practically how do you deal with
voltage thresholds that satisfy
a given static discipline?
So before I jump into building
a gate, let me try to build up
some intuition.
As is my usual practice,
I'd love to get you to build
some intuition as to how to
build a gate.
And then we'll go through the
mechanics of doing it.
So to build intuition,
let me show you an analogous
situation in fluids.
So let's say I have a cauldron
of water.
This is like a power supply.
And I need to feed this fluid
down at some output source.
And what I do in the middle is
put in a couple of taps,
faucets, all right?
And so what do these guys do?
Under what condition do you
have fluid flow out of the tube
at the other end?
You will have fluid flow if --
So let me call this A and B.
If A is on and B is on then C
has water.
Otherwise, if both A and B are
not on then C has no water.
So this is already beginning to
sound like a AND gate,
correct, where you get water
only if A and B are both turned
on.
So we're going to use this
insight, a stream of some flow
and I put things to obstruct the
flow.
And when both the obstructions
are lifted I get the output.
I want to use that intuition to
build an AND gate.
Similarly, I could build a
system that allows me to build
the following structure --
So in this scenario let me call
this --
-- the signal of A and B here.
And in this situation under
what conditions,
provided the power supply has
water, under what conditions do
I get water out?
In this situation,
it is I get water if A or B are
turned on.
So I don't need to turn both A
and B on.
If either one of them is on,
I'm going to get fluid flow
here.
So this will help us build the
inside to build the OR gate.
So that's an analogy involving
items we see in everyday life.
Let me now move into the
electrical domain.
In the electrical domain my
analogy would be something like
this.
Let's say I have a power supply
and I have two switches A and B.
And I build a little circuit
that connects this voltage
source across the bulb using a
couple of switches.
In this case,
the bulb is on if both switches
A and B are on.
My bulb turns on.
If I switch either one of them
off my bulb turns off.
So notice that I can begin
implementing things like this if
I had this element.
I had sources already.
I know how to deal with bulbs.
I model them as resistors.
So I need to do something about
this new element called a
"switch".
So let me build an abstract
device.
I'll tell you how to do that in
real life in a second.
So if I had the switch I could
build things like this.
I could put switches in series
in a circuit and get myself
something that looks like a AND
function.
So let me go ahead and build an
equivalent circuit for a switch.
So the switch has a couple of
terminals here and I have a
control.
Switches have a control and
they have a pair of terminals.
And the equivalent circuit for
this looks like this.
This is for my switch.
So when control is a 0.
Then my switch is open to give
me an open circuit in the
circuit that I've shown you
here.
And, by the same token,
if my control is a 1 then --
-- I have a connection between
in and out.
And this is a short circuit.
So, in other words,
if my switch has 0 at its
control, I'll talk about how to
get that, I have an open
circuit, and if it's a 1 then I
have a short circuit.
This is a switch going on and
off.
Now, in traditional switches
mechanical pressure is my
control signal.
If I apply mechanical pressure
my switch could turn on.
And if I take away the
mechanical pressure then I could
get an off situation.
So let's for now imagine that
we have a switch.
I still haven't told you how I
am going to get a switch in real
life.
Let's imagine you have a
switch.
It's a three terminal device.
There's a control thingamajig
coming in.
Input and an output.
So let's build the following
little circuit containing a
switch.
So what I'm going to do,
I will take a resistance RL and
plug it in here.
And connect my power supply
like so.
So the little circuit that I
build has a resistor.
And I connect the switch in
this pattern and I get a VS.
Lorenzo, you can set that up
there if you'd like.
No problem.
So I get a VS here.
Now, a couple of lectures ago I
told you that 6.002,
and for that matter,
004 and many of our other
courses deal with combinations
of elements.
And we often deal with the same
kinds of combinations again and
again and again.
We see the same sorts of
patterns happening,
and we need to begin to learn
to identify these patterns.
This is an incredibly common
pattern.
You'll see this pattern more
times in 6.002 than any other
pattern, I promise you.
A power supply connected to a
resistor and connected to a
couple of terminals of some
interesting device.
I promise there will be at
least one such pattern on the
quiz, for example.
These patterns are incredibly
common.
So let's take a look at the
interesting properties of this
pattern.
Since this pattern occurs so
commonly, I am going to create a
short form.
I have already created a short
form which is this ground node
here.
By putting ground 0 all I'm
really saying is that there is a
wire connecting these two and
that's my ground.
So I already have a short form
here.
My second short form is when I
connect a power supply to a
node.
Then what I'm going to do is
come up with yet another short
form that looks like this,
an up arrow with the voltage
written there.
This symbol simply says that
this node is connected to a
power supply with voltage,
or a voltage source voltage VS.
So I just have come up with a
slightly simpler representation
for the little pattern that I
have.
Now let's take a look at the
properties of this little
system.
Let's first look at what
happens when C is 0.
When C is 0,
let me draw the equivalent
circuit for this using the open
circuit out there.
That's what I get,
OK?
So when C is 0,
if VS is a high voltage,
let's say 5 volts,
what do you expect at the
output if C is a 0?
This voltage VS appears at V
out because this is an open
circuit here.
Remember, RL and this little
device form a voltage divider.
But since it's an open circuit
its resistance is infinity.
And so therefore in this
resistor divider all the voltage
falls across this open circuit.
So, in this case,
v out is a 1 or a high voltage.
But let's take a look at what
happens when C is a 1.
In this situation,
I have my RL,
that's what I have.
It's a short circuit at the
switch and C is a 1.
So what's the voltage v out in
this case?
Not surprisingly,
since I've shorted this node to
ground the voltage at this point
is 0.
So if I have low voltage that's
corresponding to logical 0s that
corresponds to a 0.
So I can build a simple truth
table for C and use logical
symbols here.
So when C is a 0 I get a high
at the output and when C is 1 I
get a low at the output.
Have you seen a device that
behaves like this so far?
That's a little inverter.
That's the exact behavior of an
inverter.
So this thing I've written here
is a truth table for an
inverter.
So notice with just a simple
little switch and a resistor,
I have managed to build an
inverter.
Before I go on,
I guess we have some things to
show you.
And let me pause for a couple
of seconds and do that.
First of all,
what I want to show you is the
following idea.
So as I was preparing for this
lecture last night I said,
now here I am telling the 6.002
gang that you need to learn
about analog circuits and
resistors and all of that stuff,
and you also need to learn
about digital systems and all of
that stuff.
And I said, because these two
are very commonplace and often
times they occur together.
So I said well,
if I really believe in my own
BS then there should be
something around me where I can
find both of them
instantaneously.
So I said let me do the
following experiment.
Let me close my eyes and reach
out and see what I touch.
So I closed my eyes,
reached out,
and guess what?
I touched the lonely mouse.
The mouse.
So I said let me see what is in
side the mouse.
And if I believe in my BS we
should find analog,
little components and digital
components in there,
right?
So let's see what is inside the
mouse.
All right.
There we go.
Don't try this at home,
as with many other things we do
in lecture.
Come on.
Show me what I want to see.
OK, here we go.
Not bad.
Let me show you what we have
here in this poor shattered
mouse.
That's my finger,
silly.
You should recognize this
little resistor here.
That thing with the little
bands, oh, here we go.
We'll use this.
That's a resistor.
And you'll see capacitors in
about four weeks.
That's a capacitor.
And there is a digital IC here.
That's a digital IC.
That contains a bunch of gates
inside it.
So this mouse has not made a
liar out of me.
So what I just showed you was a
little device that we use in
everyday life that has both
analog components and digital
components.
A large number of devices that
we use in daily life are this
way.
You can do the same thing to
your laptop.
You could go try it out.
And you will find a bunch of
analog components and a bunch of
digital components.
And you really,
really need to understand the
whole caboodle here.
Let me show you a fun little
demo involving gates.
Now, I want you to be very
careful here.
Lots of caveats here.
If your grandmother asks you
how big is a gate don't say this
big.
This is how big gates used to
be, I would say,
when they were first invented.
When they built gates out of
discrete vacuum tubes and so on,
this is how big a gate used to
be.
This is roughly that big.
Today in a chip,
in a small VLSI,
very large scaled integrated
circuit in a chip,
which is about 1 cm on the
side, how many gates do you
think I can fit in a thumbnail
sized chip?
Any guesses?
With today's technology,
how many gates can I fit on a
chip?
It has to be more than a
million because I just told you
that Pentium IV was 20 million
and that was a year ago.
How many?
40 million is a good guess.
So on the order of 40 to 80
million gates in a 1 square
centimeter.
Intel just announced that they
will be shipping a chip
containing 1 billion switches.
Remember, this whole thing is a
gate, right?
Inverter, a resistor and a
switch.
This thing is a switch.
So Intel is going to be
shipping something containing a
billion of those little
elements.
Just keep those large numbers
in mind.
So here is a little circuit
that I showed you here,
A, B, the NAND gate,
the NAND gate at the output and
the inverter.
So this output A is going to be
1 whenever either A or B is off.
So the output is a 1 in this
case when both A and B are off.
I turn A to 1,
output is still a 1.
So the moment I turn both of
these inputs into a 1,
these are 1s,
the output goes to 0.
That's behavior for NAND gate.
If I switch any one of the
inputs to a 0 the output should
go to a 1.
Similarly, for the inverter
here, when the input is a 0 the
output is a 1.
And when I switch it so should
the output.
Now imagine a circuit,
a little chip containing
billions of these devices.
And just imagine all of these
1s and 0s flying around.
So one simple switch in the
input, like a click of a
keystroke could actually cause a
billion signals in your circuit
to be flipping around.
And that causes some fun stuff
to happen, which we will learn
about a few months from now.
But for now that's a quick show
of a little circuit that looks
like that.
Let me go back to talking about
building other types of gates.
So that was an inverter.
So now you know.
You're almost halfway to being
able to build a Pentium IV.
You've come all the way from
nature to gates.
And Pentium IV contains 20
million of them so you now know
how gates are built.
So that's an inverter.
Let's look at how we can build
other forms of gates.
To build another gate let me do
this.
How about this pattern?
If I build a pattern like this
with A and B coming in here and
I put two switches with their
inputs in and out,
so two switches in series.
Let's write down the truth
table for what this looks like.
Let's see.
When A and B are both 0,
what should the output be?
These are both off so the
output is directly VS which is a
high.
When either of these switches
is off 0-1 or 1-0.
If either switch is off then
this node is cut off from
ground.
There is no current flowing
here.
So this entire voltage drops
across this infinite resistance
here, and so I get 1s at the
output as well.
If both switches are on what
happens?
If both A and B are on then I
get a short circuit to ground
and my output is a 0.
So can someone tell me what
gate this is?
Awesome.
We just build a NAND gate.
This is unbelievable.
Five lectures and you've
already come all the way from
nature to the primitive building
blocks of microprocessors.
It's pretty amazing.
So what about this one here?
What's this?
I haven't told you this before
but if an AND gate becomes a
NAND gate, this is kind of an OR
arrangement, what should an OR
become?
NOR.
It's all completely logical.
So you can go home and practice
a truth table for this.
A, B and C.
I'll just fill in one of the
rows.
So in this particular
situation, if both A and B are
0, if A is 0 and B is 0,
both the switches are off,
so it's as if this little
sucker here is cut off from
ground and VS falls across from
C to ground here and the output
is a 1, so on and so forth.
So I can build other
interesting forms of gates.
So let's say I build something
that looks like this.
I build something like this.
You can write the truth table
for this or you can look at this
and write down the function that
this one supports.
Notice that this output here is
going to be a high only when
both of these are not connected
to ground.
And if you stare at it some
more the function this one
presents, this is my AND
function.
Suppose this one didn't exist,
that would be my AND function.
But because this one exists
that's in an OR configuration
and so I get a C.
And so because of that I get
something that looks like this.
So this is my A dot B,
this is my plus because of a
parallel here,
and ultimately this caused an
inversion in this gate.
So the primitive pattern has a
generic inversion built into the
output.
That is why they commonly end
up building NAND gates and NOR
gates and so on as the simplest
gates.
We don't build AND gates and OR
How can I convert this one to
an AND gate?
Anybody?
Put an inverter on the output.
So what I can do is take this
little sucker here,
put an inverter here and I get
an AND gate.
So the real primitives in
circuits tend to be NANDs and
NORs.
OK.
So the real practical among you
should be saying at this point
all right, all right,
I buy this, if there existed a
switch.
I know exactly how to go from
nature to building Pentium IVs
if there exists a switch.
So that the obvious next step
for me is to show you a switch,
a physical switch device.
And to introduce a switch
device, let me show you a three
terminal element.
Remember, the switch has three
terminals, an input,
output and something called the
control, C.
So I'm going to introduce a new
primitive element called "The
MOSFET Device".
MOSFET stands for metal-oxide
semiconductor field-effect
transistor.
This is shortened to FET or
Now I'm going to show you that
this works like a switch.
And before I do that,
in fact, let me do that first.
Then I'll show you something
else.
So this device has the
following symbol.
It has a terminal called a
gate, the drain and the source.
Gate, drain and source.
Three terminals.
This is the primitive element
that forms virtually every
electronic component built
today.
This is the foundation of the
universe.
So this little MOSFET device,
we can look at how it behaves.
I'll show you this thing on the
screen in a second,
but this guy behaves very much
like this device I was
postulating earlier.
Let's take a look at this
device on the scope.
To do so let me label some
voltages and currents.
So let me label this voltage as
vDS.
Let me label this voltage as
vGS between the gate and the
source.
And let me label the current
coming into this node iG.
In this device,
the physical device that I'm
going to show you,
the current going into the gate
is always 0.
So iG is always going to be 0
for 6.002.
In real life there is some
leakage and so on.
But in 6.002 for now we deal
with a very simple abstract
model, iG is 0.
And let me label the current
here as iDS.
To be correct with the
nomenclation,
the current into node D should
be labeled iD,
but because iG is 0 iD flows
out through the source as well,
so I would simply call it iDS
just so that I can show that vDS
and iDS are the two voltages and
currents that I am going to deal
with.
So that's my little device
here.
And notice that the source
terminal is common.
I use the source both for the
control GS and I use the source
for the drain as well.
So you can view this as input,
view this as out,
and you can view this,
if you like,
as the control abstractly.
So let me show you a plot of
how this behaves.
To understand how it behaves,
I can draw an equivalent
circuit for it.
So in this particular
situation, if its behavior is
characterized by the voltage
applied to vGS.
Much like the control on the
switch, vGS is my control.
So if vGS is 0,
oh, I'm sorry.
If vGS is greater than or equal
to some threshold voltage VT --
So vGS, the voltage applied
here is greater than some
voltage, VT, a threshold
voltage, or the pressure of the
switch is greater than some
threshold pressure then this guy
behaves like a short circuit.
This is iDS,
this is my drain and this is my
source.
So if the voltage applied
between the gate and the source
is higher than some threshold
then this behaves like a short
circuit.
Similarly, if the voltage vGS
is less than some threshold VT
then in that situation --
-- I get an open circuit.
And when I have an open circuit
between D and S then the current
iDS is going to be 0.
So this is the idealized model.
And this idealized model is
called "the switch model of the
MOSFET".
The switch model or the S model
of the MOSFET.
Well, if you want to see the
internals of the MOSFET,
I won't cover that in lecture
or recitation.
You can look at the section,
I believe Section 6.7 of the
course notes.
That has the internal structure
of the MOSFET and how you
physically construct such a
device.
So what I can do here is step
back and stare at the device for
a second or two.
And what it says is that if I
apply a lot of pressure,
if vGS is greater than a
threshold VT then I get a short
circuit here just like my
switch.
When in doubt think faucet.
If you put pressure on the
faucet, think of this as
closing, and when I open it,
when vGS goes less than VD,
less than a threshold,
I take off the pressure and
then it becomes an open circuit.
So I can plot the following.
Much like I plotted the iV
characteristics of two terminal
elements, I can plot the iV
characteristics of this three
terminal element in the
following way.
I can focus on two terminals
and look at vDS and iDS for that
terminal pair and draw the
curves for how it will behave as
I change vGS that I applied.
So what I'm going to show you
is that if vGS is less than a
threshold then this behaves like
a open circuit.
So no matter what the voltage
is the current is 0.
Similarly, if vGS greater than
equal to some threshold voltage
then I get the behavior iV curve
of a short circuit where the
current can be anything and
controlled by external forces
like in any short circuit.
So let me show you on the
screen.
Lorenzo has kindly put the
graph up already.
So I'm showing the iV curve of
a switch.
Notice that when vGS is greater
than VT, greater than a
threshold I get the vertical
line corresponding to a short
circuit.
Is it this one?
This one.
There we go.
So what I'm going to do here is
I'm going to reduce vGS to below
VT.
What should you see happening?
The curve, from being a short
circuit, should hammer down to
becoming an open circuit.
That's the curve for an open
circuit as I drew out there for
you.
VGS pressure ain't enough.
Lots of pressure,
boom, it's a short circuit.
I really like to think of this
pressure analogy if I get
confused whenever I look at a
MOS transistor and I need to
look at vGS and so on I always
think vGS is greater than VT.
Lots of pressure on the switch
it turns on.
Just remember that,
and then you won't forget this
vGS thing here.
So that's the behavior of a
switch.
And so viola,
there's our switch.
So I've given you a three
terminal element that is a
switch that is controlled like a
mechanical switch.
So I can build a,
if I replace --
This was my switch earlier.
And what I can do is replace
this with my MOSFET and that's
what I get.
And I won't bother showing you
this is your inverter.
All of that has replaced the
abstract switch with a physical
switch which behaves as shown in
the graph up there.
And so I apply an input here
and I take the output here.
So as 6.002 you could look at
this and say ah-ha,
that is an inverter.
When you go to 004 what you
will do is build this triangle
and a circle around it and you
will ignore what's inside and
just look at that.
So in 002 we showed you that
the internals look like a
pattern with a MOSFET and a
resistor, but it's really the
abstract inverter looking in
from the outside.
I'm just going to close the
loop inside the digital gate,
and this was inside your little
inverter with a resistor and a
switch.
Let me continue with this for a
little longer here --
-- and do something that we
like to do a lot,
which is plot what are called
input / output curves.
So let's say the voltage
applied here is v in and let's
call this v out.
For fun let's plot a v in
versus v out for this inverter.
So when input is a 0,
let's say VT is 1 volt for the
inverter.
The threshold voltage is 1
volt.
The threshold pressure is 1
So when input is a 0,
and let's say VS is 5 volts.
So when the input is a 0,
this guy is turned off.
So what's the output?
What's the output voltage?
If this is turned off,
what's the output voltage?
It's the supply.
The supply directly shows up
here.
And so as long as the input is
0 the output is at 5 volts.
And this is true until the
input reaches 1 volt.
As long as the input is less
than 1 volt my output stays
high.
And then when my input exceeds
or hits 1 volt then at that
point the switch turns on and
the MOSFET turns on and shorts
the output to ground in which
case boom, this is what I get.
And then, no matter how much I
increase the input,
my switch stays on and the
output follows a zero volts at
the output.
So this is my v in versus v out
curve for the inverter.
One of the interesting things
that we do a lot is see whether
this satisfies some voltage
threshold.
So let's say I have a VOL of
0.5 volts, VOH of 4.5,
VIL of 0.9 and VIH of 4.1
volts.
So VOL says in its low value is
the output less than 0.5?
Yup, output less than 0.5.
In its high is it more than
4.5?
Yup, it's more than 4.5.
Does it recognize all values
below VIL as a low input?
Yup.
So anything below 0.9 or 1 for
that matter is viewed as a low.
That's good.
So these pass.
And high, anything above 4.1,
is that treated as a high?
Yes.
So anything above 4.1 is
treated as a high and the output
goes low.
So therefore this inverter that
I've designed for you here
satisfies the static discipline
and this inverter can be used in
circuits or other devices that
conform to this value here.
In your recitation,
you will look at a slightly
more detailed model of the
switch where the switch behaves
like a resistor.